à l'époque ce type là bas ce type était
vraiment galère il était vraiment galère
il a d'ailleurs si je te limite manger
des sans logis semant le plus fatigué le
matériel cinq ans à l'époque s'est
vraiment régalé avec stomy notre frère
je vois ce tome i avec cyril on prenait
tout le temps ensemble et on a décidé de
faire un film à larache on a écrit un
scénario en une semaine en une heure en
une rumeur allez vas-y thérapie on
raconte son rôle s'il te plait pas
c'était ton mec dans le scénario
d'ailleurs j'ai jamais été payé sur ce
film non mais tu seras jamais la mission
c'est une demande de rançon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors serez alors vas-y que je continue
je pense qu'on a les images je pense
qu'on a retrouvé des images de fond on
peut voir
[Musique]
tout ça pour toi c'était parce que ça
m'a bien fait rire toute fraude à
l'avenir gardes pour toi qui tous pour
toi g pas c'est quoi ça c'est quoi ça
c'est quoi pour moi regarde mon
rendement
[Musique]
g
[Applaudissements]
si neymar et ouvre alors c'est
incroyable pathé grand air
[Applaudissements]
hier
[Musique]
moi je les yeux je suis dégaine tu es
devenu incontrôlable dans cette élection
ont joué les forcenés ça n'est pas le
deuxième extrait si oui
[Musique]
si vous voulez un deuxième extrait vous
[Applaudissements]
vous l'un d'eux à des shows deuxième
on apprend on à est ce que la régie peut
nous dire sur la l'expression là on la
leur avant noël si on est content de
l'arrivée son bateau juste avant qu'ils
disent si on à l'excès ou pas je
rappelle bien entendu accord sur ces 8
ces personnes là je vous dis elle vous
ramèneront rien ne s'est pas copiner
avec ces gars là vous directement